bonsoir accès à une personne merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
vous êtes en grève de la faim depuis
quatre jours vous souhaitez ainsi
alerter sur la détresse des saisonniers
on n'en parle pas c'est selon vous tout
à fait il ya il ya un silence sur ce qui
se passe à lourdes il faut savoir qu'on
a perdu 92 % du chiffre d'affaires pour
la saison d'amis de 21 et que au moment
où est intervenue le confinement on
n'était pas sous contrat on devait
signer de contrat quelques jours
quelques semaines après et depuis nous
n'avons pas le chômage partiel nous
seuls louis donc 2400 et nous épuisons
le droit au chômage depuis le mois de
mars
certains déjà épuisé leurs droits se
retrouvent au rsa est de plus en plus
tombe au rsa et c'est une situation
dramatique que nous irons à londres
alors c'est vrai que emmanuel macron
hier n'a pas dû vous consoler beaucoup
notamment les stations de ski alors ça
ne vous concerne pas directement mais ça
concerne évidemment des milliers de
saisonniers les stations de ski qui ne
vont pas rouvrir cet hiver en tout cas
pour les fêtes de noël
on imagine une immense déception ça a dû
créer une forme de panique dans le
secteur oui tout à fait parce que on est
déjà débordé soul et le marché de
l'emploi déjà débordés et là on va se
retrouver également avec les saisonniers
qui vont vivre la même chose un station
que ce que nous avons vécu au mois de
mars à on s'efforce d'alerté et de
prévenir parce que les dispositions du
chômage partiel qui sont prises à 100%
en fait il faut savoir qu'il reste des
charges aux employeurs et qui les pousse
souvent vu du manque de visibilité sur
les réservations et sur l'ouverture
possible à un moment donné dans la
saison hivernale vont certainement
peut-être prendre des précautions et ne
pas recruter comme madame bande l'avait
l'avait indiqué dans un tweet
ça veut dire concrètement pour bien que
l'on comprenne la situation des
saisonniers qui sont environ 2400 je
crois qu'on concernés pas de signature
de contrats non pas de chômage
pour ainsi dire et baden alors les aides
nous avons un forum qui va commencer
bientôt nous allons rencontrer les
autorités de notre
les autorités locales afin de trouver
des solutions d'urgence pour pour tous
les travailleurs qui sont mis de côté
dans ces dispositifs et mais c'est
insuffisant et c'est pour ça que j'ai
entamé donc cette grève de la faim parce
que l'urgence n'est pas assez prise en
compte de savoir qu'on attend depuis
huit mois
noël arrive et il ya des situations
dramatiques autour de nous nous avons
créé un comptoir alimentaire nous avons
quand même de l'aide de la municipalité
et du de la région pour pour fournir
donc des colis alimentaires mais nous ce
qu'on réclame ans et la dignité
nous sommes des travailleurs nous avons
nous faisons une carrière à lourdes il
s'agit d'un tourisme spirituel très
particulier et nous ne pouvons pas nous
retourner sur d'autres saison
puisqu'elle est la saison dure de pâques
à fin octobre
alors le président a tout de même parlé
d'une aide exceptionnelle
il a aussi évoqué ce principe de jeunes
une solution c'est tout même une source
d'espoir en vous oui oui c'est une
source d'espoir nous attendons avec
impatience les annonces qui vont être
faite j'espère d'ici quelques jours
parce que j'ai l'estomac et s'ils
tombent les voilà c'est l'année blanche
les intermittents du spectacle parce
qu'ils étaient reconnus dans leur statut
d'intermittent ont bénéficié de l'année
blanche nous prouve réclame c'est la
même chose nous sommes d'intermittent du
et du travail la lourde comme beaucoup
en france deux millions deux cent mille
en fait on des carrières morcelées des
contrats contrats des cdd et des cdi et
ceux là on les a complètement oublié et
il serait temps maintenant qu'on fasse
quelque chose de secours eux sachant que
le deuxième confinement a fait
énormément de mal
en plus du premier continent et de la
perte de la saison pour nous abonde
merci en tout cas c'est la personne
d'avoir été avec nous d'avoir accepté de
témoigner en direct sur rt france